Andy Dalton here on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing Andy doing well how are
you doing I'm doing fine how would you
describe the first month of the season
Andy up and down for sure you know it's
not the start that we wanted but you
know for us to come on get a win
yesterday so a much-needed win and so
hopefully we can use it as momentum
going into this week why it looks just
from the naked eye that this offense
looks more crisp and you're more
comfortable and everybody else is
playing more comfortably in it since the
coordinator changed with bill laser is
that a fair assessment Andy yeah I think
guys are playing with confidence and
like I said we're playing better I think
we're executing better as well and so
you know whatever it takes at this point
I mean for us we we wanted to come out
and get a win yesterday and we were able
to do that and so yeah we got to keep
finding ways to win moving forward now I
understand when I ask you a question
that way Andy look I've done this longer
but then if you gave an answer in the
affirmative that it would seem like you
were throwing your old offensive
coordinator under the bus so let me put
it this way what what what are you guys
doing differently scheme wise over the
last couple of weeks yeah I think first
things that things are matching up
running past things look the same so you
know we're not giving any tips there and
you know so I think I think for us I
think it's well like I said earlier part
of it is yeah just the execution of it
but other things there are some things
scheme wise that were that we are doing
differently that you know we're trying
to find a way to take advantage of the
deviance of looks that we're getting
Andy don't joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show what about you personally I
know when I was there after that week
two loss on Thursday Night Football in
Cincinnati there was a lot of folks
criticizing you publicly huh do you hear
that noise Andy I mean it's hard not to
hear it even if you're trying not to but
you can't worry about it yeah all you
can worry about is uh
doing what you know how to do you know
I've played this game long enough but
I've been around a while now and so you
know I understand how it all works and
for me and just put my head down working
and try to try to find a way to
to win the next week and to play better
and so I feel like we've done that the
last couple weeks obviously we didn't
win two weeks ago in Green Bay you know
the tough loss in overtime but we played
a lot better and so I think we we played
better the last two weeks and we gotta
keep it going
what's your relationship with Marvin
Lewis and he hears so much about
quarterback coach relationships and the
you know there will there always an
offensive guru with the quarterback
obviously Marvin's got a defensive
background what is your relationship
like with him yeah we've got a good
relationship there's a lot of you know
back and forth talk when things need to
happen and things need to change and
when we need to do things differently
and so I think we've got a great
relationship and you know that's grown
as as time has gone on can you give me a
for example like what does he say I mean
when does he when does he chime in I
feel like you know he's not someone
that's saying something all the time
especially to the offense you know like
you say he's a demon Samana coach but
when he feels that like it's necessary
that the things need to be said he's
gonna say it and so yeah it's hard to
think of just a specific example right
now but it's just kind of how his
personality is and how he handles things
here and then one thing that definitely
impressed upon me and impressed me was
when things were going brutally there's
no other way to put it to start the
season AJ McCarron came out and said
yeah you know what I'd like to start but
I love Andy Dalton he's a friend he's
our quarterback and everybody should
pipe down and row in the same direction
that what did that mean to you to hear
that Andy yeah I have a great
relationship ever since he's been here
you know we've become good friends and
so I mean for him to come out and say
that it obviously means a lot you have
the supportive you know got it's the
backup but also a teammate and so yeah
I'm in a lot that he would say something
like that your beer competitor though -
do you ever want to just pound your
chest and saying you know I've done some
stuff around here yeah I think there's
some times where it's uh you know when
things are going exactly the way you
want - everybody everybody forms an
opinion but you know
feel like we've accomplished a lot since
I've been here and I've been able to do
to do some good things here and so
that's one of the things where you don't
worry about what everybody's saying you
just go out and and you know find a way
to play the best you can Andy Dalton
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
so now you got the Buffalo Bills I don't
know if you you were playing at the same
time that they were playing as well they
just had a very impressive victory and
they're feeling very good about
themselves with their new head coach
coming in what challenges do they
present to you this week Andy yeah
they're really good defensively and
obviously when you know they can slow
down an offense like Atlanta you know
obviously they're doing something right
and I know that they can get after the
quarterback and that can rush the passer
really well and so you know we'll kind
of see once we watch some some of these
guys and come up with a game plan I'm
sure we'll have something that will be
ready for him for me and AJ Green is he
a happier guy when the ball is fed his
way and he's very quiet but he was a
little bit vocal a couple weeks ago see
a better is he bet just easier to be
around when he gets fed the football
yeah I think that's one thing about that
AJ is uh you know he he's a he's a team
guy all he cares about is winning but
when he feels like he can he can do some
things to help us win I think he became
a little vocal and it's what we needed
and so but yeah I mean you want to get
him the ball as much as you can because
he's the best player on offense and
we're talking about young running backs
in the difference that they've been
making all over the place
rookie running backs you've got one in
Joe Mixon how is he mixed in with the
team Andy since coming off the campus at
Oklahoma and a lot discussed about his
past in his background you know it's one
of the things a lot of people talked
about it with him coming here and in his
past obviously he did something that you
know is wrong and you know he can't get
that back but you know he's trying to do
everything he can now to prove that he's
a changed person and it's not gonna let
anything like that happen again but you
know I think he was well received from
the beginning I think we've got a lot of
good teammates on the team just to
surround him and kind of like you know
keep put him under our wing and and help
him out but you know he's done it he's
done a great job ever since he's been
here he's he's a super talented guy
and you know I'm glad we've got we've
got a guy like that before I let you go
t see you sitting there eight in the top
25 and the college football poll do you
think that they've got a playoff team I
think they're gonna have some tests for
coming up obviously they got West
Virginia this week and I think game days
there so it would be a lot of a lot of
excitement around that and but they're
playing well I know coach person is
gonna get his guys ready he always does
and I'm excited to watch to see how the
season plays off you know I'm sure
you're you're gonna be watching them
when they take on Baker Mayfield what do
you think of that kid Andy watching him
play at the at the collegiate level yeah
I mean he's played really well it's one
this guy he kind of does it all I mean
he's uh you know he can run he can throw
you know he just kind of make stuff
happen and it's for him to get to get
that big win he had at Ohio State and
and just the way they play as I think
you know he's really talented and I know
that they've got a really good team so
there may be you know next win that you
have where you feel that you've been
wrong and you've been doubted Andy won't
you just take the Bengals flag and
planted this planet in the middle of
opposed you do that in Pittsburgh what
do you think if you beat the Steelers in
a couple weeks how do you think how do
you think that would go yeah I think
everybody would just block didn't eat I
think and you're in the previous Bengals
iteration TJ who Sherman's Auto wiped
his feet with the Terrible Towel and
he's still public enemy number one up
there in Western PA Ford yes if you do
anything with that Terrible Towel
they're gonna they're gonna react to
that take care of yourself Andy good
chat yeah thanks you gotta add Andy
Dalton 14 on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy